there isn't anything that you can
possibly do that makes you more
competent in everything you do then to
learn how to communicate never make a
point without a story and never tell a
story without a point I'll give you a
couple of key things on speaking for
everybody wanna be happy
build a life not just a business so
today let's leave your best believe life
and learn how to master your
communication skills
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one believe in what you say with IDI
midlet my first time I talked I
literally went up and blanked out
like I literally could not think I could
not see the card how I fixed it speaking
was over time but I'll give you a couple
key things on speaking for everybody one
I had to I had to figure out you know
what someone said to me cuz you love
baseball
you don't stutter when you talk about
baseball you don't get insecure I go
well I love that and I believe in it
they're like oh you don't you know you
talk about your kids you're great I
thought oh there's a correlation here
between me actually saying what I
believe and what I'm passionate about in
my ability to communicate it and so that
now my first layer is always I must be
passionate about it and I must believe
it and I'm never doing an impression of
another person so I always come from a
place of saying what I really believe
because you can't transfer to somebody
that which you don't experience yourself
I can give you passion I can give you
energy I can give you my belief if I'm
experiencing it big key is a speaker
I'll give everybody stop trying to
convince everybody of what you're saying
that's not the threshold of being a good
communicator people do not need to
believe what you're saying they need to
believe you believe what you're saying
and as long as they believe you believe
what you're saying you're an effective
speaker I stopped trying to get people
to believe me there's a neediness
there's a salesmanship to that I stopped
that it's a subtle difference I just
want you to believe I believe it
that's influence influences you believe
I believe it
number two be open to the unknown with
simon Sinek rarely are we instant
experts you may have a particular gift
or affinity toward something but you
still get better you know people would
pay me high compliments when I started
speaking and then people who've seen me
a year or two later say that I'm even
better and I feel it why is that because
you you you learn more you know I think
that hubris is dangerous I think to
think that you're an expert in anything
is a foolish pursuit you're never you're
never as good as you could be there's
always room for improvement
there's always room to get better you
know that does mean you have to listen
to all the advice just you know not
necessarily does everybody know best but
but to believe that you can be better
and to believe that you can offer more
is a constant pursuit you know I used to
think being a public speaker meant being
poised and presenting in a way that was
compelling and speaking at the right
pace and that's that's a part of it but
but I have been taking more risks lately
doing things that are very unstructured
and very uncomfortable and I will now do
like if I have an hour to speak I'd
rather speak for 20 minutes and do 40
minutes worth of questions and who knows
how that's gonna go and that to me is
the best and so I'm a better speaker
because now I'm Way more open to the
unknown we're a few years ago that that
would've scared me also if you want to
learn how to build your confidence check
out my 250 for confident series it's
free the link is in the description
below
and even though I'm gonna sell you the
most beautiful hammer I'm not gonna
guarantee the structural integrity of
the house if you're gonna speak
effectively you have to know way more
than you're talking about rule number
three practice more with Jordan Peterson
I'm incredibly nervous to talk in front
of you because you've got to be one of
the most formidable people that I've
ever heard of or ever listened to ever
seen so my question is again you're one
of the best communicators that I've ever
listened to if I could be half as good
at you or at communicating as you are I
would be set how can I teach myself to
do that practice
you know really like well there's a
couple of things is helps to read a lot
it really helped to write so if you want
to make yourself articulate which is a
very good idea then not only should you
read but you should write down what you
think and if you can do that a little
bit every day 15 minutes maybe you could
steal 15 minutes and do it every day but
if you do that for 10 years you really
straighten out your thinking if you're
gonna speak effectively you have to know
way more than you're talking about you
know so if you this is often difficult
for beginning lecturers at university
because they'll do a lecture on a topic
but they only know as much as they're
saying in the lecture and they get kind
of stuck to their notes because of it
but you want to know ten times as much
as you are saying in the lecture and
then you can specify a stepping path
through it and elaborate with the other
things that you know but to do that you
have to do a lot of reading but you also
have to do a lot of reading because
that's where the synthesize that's where
the synthesizing comes so that's on the
input side and then on the output side
well there's some tricks techniques
let's say is like if you're speaking in
front of a group you are not delivering
a talk to a group that's not what you're
doing the talk isn't a package thing
that you present to a group there isn't
a group there's a bunch of individuals
and you talk to them so when I talk to a
group I always talk to people one at a
time and that makes it easier to because
you know how to talk to a person it's
like can you talk to a thousand people
well probably not because it's too
intimidating but there isn't a thousand
people there there's a thousand
individuals and so you just look at an
individual and you say something and you
can tell if they're engaged they look
confused or they look interested or they
look angry or they look bored or maybe
they're asleep in which case you look at
someone else and they give you feedback
about how you're doing and so one thing
is to to have something to say yeah but
there
thing is pay attention to who you're
talking to because unless you're very
badly socialized and that seems unlikely
in your case because you know you
present yourself at least moderately
well you know and well I mean I don't
know you very well but at first but on
first sight you know you're doing fine
so the probability that if you pay
attention to the individuals that you're
talking to that your natural wealth of
social skill will manifest itself is
extremely high and so you don't deliver
a talk to an audience that's a really
bad way of thinking about you're
actually engaged in a conversation with
an audience even if they're not talking
they're nodding and shifting position
and you know looking like this or and
you can you can pull all that in and and
and use it to govern the level at which
you're addressing the entire audience so
the last thing I would say is well
having the aim to be a good communicator
is a good start and you think well I
could bunch us that to some degree well
there isn't anything that you can
possibly this is the whole point of a
liberal education there isn't anything
that you can possibly do that makes you
more competent in everything you do than
to learn how to communicate I don't care
if you're gonna be a carpenter I mean
being a carpenter by the way is very
difficult especially if you're a good
carpenter but if you're good at
communicating as a carpenter you're like
ten times better as a carpenter so the
and this is something that the liberal
arts colleges I think and I don't know
if they've forgotten it but they don't
do a very good job of marketing it's
like what's the use of a bachelor's
degree a Bachelor of Arts it's like well
you can think you can write you can
speak you've read something it's like
the economic value that is incalculable
the people that I've watched in my life
have been spectacularly successful are
they have skills clearly that that's a
minimum precondition but they're also
very very good at articulating
themselves and so whenever they
negotiate they're successful well that's
kind of like the deaf
of success in life right you negotiate
and your six doesn't mean you win
because if you're a good negotiator if
you're really good negotiator everybody
walks away from the negotiation thrilled
and so then people line up to do things
with you so and that's all that's all
dependent on your ability to communicate
so practice rule number four master
storytelling with Les Brown never make a
point without a story and never tell a
story without a point that's number one
that's keen because stories can be used
to travel to people's lives yeah not
just anchor two points but it creates a
significant emotional event and that's
how human behaviors transform we have
emotionally an emotional memory the next
thing in and speaking there is some fear
and that fear is always there I never
assumed that I know where that audience
going to believe each audience they have
their own personality and each audience
their audience inside of each audience
that's separated by age by race by
income by education the other thing
that's crucial in speaking is that as
you speak and as you look at the
audience always take the time to find
out who they are and all thy getting get
understanding so I have a needs
assessment that I sent out and I asked
some questions you know what are the
things that you want this audience to
walk away with what are the things that
you've done things that that's stressing
you out what's the unspoken conversation
so I sent out this needs assessment I
talked with a CEO I do research to find
out their mission statement I talked the
marketing director and then I interview
the top performers if it's of sales
organization I talked to the top
performers and then the next step I
interview people in the audience if you
were in my position what are the things
that people in the audience need to hear
if you were in my position that you
would suggest I asked them individually
these five people and then when I'm on
stage I integrate that I marry that to
navigate an experience as I said Oliver
Wendell Holmes said that once a man a
woman
mine has been expanded with an idea
concept or experience it could never be
satisfied to going back to where it was
so when you bring all those elements in
there with humor with quotes statistics
and stories you're able to create
special moments that can transform that
audience the other thing when you tell a
story don't just tell the story
experience the story and the audience
will go there when you see the story
yeah it's got to be the story the
embodiment of the story so that the
audience as a result of hearing it that
they can't rest that you start showing
up in their dreams and rule number five
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is commit emotionally with me this
is where a lot of entrepreneurs really
fall down you've got your powerful
opinion you know what you stand for you
know what you're trying to communicate
but when you get in front of a camera or
when you get down to writing it doesn't
sway people it's not emotional enough
you could be saying all the best words
when you get in front of a camera to
make a video but because you are talking
in a very boring very non exciting
manner and because you're so worried
about saying the perfect words that you
are memorizing something or you are
looking at your script or trying to read
from a teleprompter nobody is going to
care or listen to you you need to have
emotional commitment you need to feel
the thing and how important it is while
you are saying it for me I'm envisioning
all of you I'm envisioning all the
entrepreneurs that I've worked with who
have these are amazing ideas and they
never get them out because they can't
communicate and even though I'm sitting
here in an office by myself and there's
nobody around to actually connect with
I'm just talking to a camera I'm trying
to channel you I'm trying to channel all
the people that I've connected with and
seen and I want to make sure that your
business does well thank you getting
this self
as part of that which is why I'm doing
this video and hopefully the care the
love the energy comes through in the
content that I make and so sales and
convincing people not enough against
what they want but in a positive way
like this is something that you guys can
get together on is about the energy
transfer you are not just selling a
concept or an idea you are transferring
energy whoever is more confident wins
whoever is more convincing wins and it's
usually from whoever believes in their
thing more if you absolutely believe in
your thing and that this is right and
it's for them when they need to do this
thing because it's in their best
interest not because they're just trying
to sell something down their throat but
you really really really really care and
if they feel that care as opposed to
just words that you're saying that's how
you bring them on board it's great to
have the best words but more important
is the emotional commitment that you
have behind them now I've got a special
bonus cut from Dan Locke on how to
create participation energy that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
questions time to go from just watching
a video to taking action here we go
question number one where in your week
will you commit to practicing your
communication skills number two what is
the most important message that you
believe in that you need to spread and
number three what will you remind
yourself up before filming so that you
will commit emotionally to the message I
always want to create what I call a
participation energy participation
energy meaning I want them to
participate so imagine if I'm on stage
and I'm just talking and talking and
talking and talking and lecturing right
and preaching about certain concepts
well it's easy to get nervous because
you always worried about if I'm saying
the right thing but if I have a
participation energy going on a learning
energy a a fun energy going on example I
would always ask them and how many of
you believe in this how many agree with
that how many ever experienced this I
get them to put up their hand I get them
to yell back the answer I get them to
fill in the blank I gave them to
discussion talking among each other when
I create that kind of safe and
gee celebration energy learning energy
guess what you get less nervous
if you want to master your communication
skills with Stephen Kelly check out
their video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
we're of value for you guys and we're
helping you grow your businesses be
successful live your dreams so if we can
do that you know